primeiro eu gostaria de dizer que é um
privilégio estar aqui
esse evento está fantástico ele é um
tributo ao que o ser humano tem de
melhor que é a capacidade de pensar se o
ted existe é porque o ser humano
consegue pensar e quando conseguimos
pensar
geralmente eles dão uma coisa que chama
prêmio nobel na maioria das vezes
ficamos apenas raciocinando o que mais
me provocou quando eu vi a temática da
desconexão foi ambivalência ambivalência
ambivalência no sentido de pensar assim
pra eu estar conectado em algo eu
preciso me desconectar de muitos outros
alvos pra eu me desconectar eu preciso
me conectar como é bom às vezes
desconectar do monte de coisas de uma
idéia ultrapassada de um trauma de um
sentimento de tristeza de um monte de
gente que atazana nossa vida mas como é
bom às vezes se conectar com algo que
nos transforma como é bom às vezes se
conectar com aquilo que está dentro de
mim e dentro de você
eu adoro música clássica um dos dos que
eu mais sou apaixonado é o senhor ludwig
van beethoven
um dos meus livros eu fiz uma provocação
dizendo a tim será que beethoven esse
grande pianista e maestro
se na época dele não existisse o piano
será que ele teria sido quem ele foi a
resposta de maneira categórica
seria assim provavelmente o inventor do
piano
nesse contexto o problema que deu que na
mesma época juntou beethoven e o piano e
deu no que deu e você vai passar por
essa existência esse homem está
imortalizado
este homem como eu e você que nasceu com
o mesmo instrumento dois braços duas
pernas com a mesma capacidade encefálica
mas ele fez algo diferente você já
encontrou seu piano
que música que você tem tocado quando
você toca sua música por mais as vezes
que seja uma música triste ela te
encanta
você está passando como a maioria que
nasce em branco e morre cópia
quando você olha pra dentro de você
aquela pergunta filosófica
quem é você eu já começo dizendo que se
teve um lugar aonde você sentiu
plenamente feliz não existia a tristeza
não existia fome existia frio não
existia nada nada que você precisa se
preocupar
foi aqui dentro do útero materno
a partir do momento que você saiu dali
algo se apresentou na sua frente
tanto é que na psicanálise nós dizemos
que essa coisa que as pessoas chamam de
alegria de felicidade
na verdade a busca por esse instante por
esse momento
esse momento que ali dentro você foi
plenamente satisfeito nada lhe faltava e
aí você passamos pela vida buscando
buscando momentos e cada momento cada
instante ele é transformador
tem gente que diz que às vezes outras
pessoas demoram dez anos para mudar
mentira tem pessoas que às vezes
precisam de dez anos para se preparar
para um momento porque o momento é algo
rápido mas ele é transformador
ele é algo que abre rotas e quando nós
olhamos para esse mundo
esse mundo contemporâneo que na mensagem
do michel ficou vem trazendo a
ortopedista a são cada vez mais as
coisas estão ortopedia zados vocês viram
que aquela foto do primeiro slide né do
pokémon até um paciente meu brincou o
torcedor não instalar o aplicativo para
ver como que é
imagina só você sai na rua e vê um monte
de pokémons se vê um monte de zumbis
você vê um monte de vidas que estão
escorregando pelas mãos
você tem uma linha nação e se você
comparar o mundo virtual com o mundo
real
parece que a coisa não combina imagine
você encontrando com um dos seus amigos
e pára na rua de goa hoje eu comi um
prato de macarrão hoje eu estou vestindo
uma camisa preta hoje eu estou com o
sapato tal seu amigo vai lavar a cara tá
meio louco mas parece que no mundo
virtual a coisa tem funcionado seria
estupidez da minha parte dizer que a
tecnologia não tem nos ajudado pelo
contrário estou aqui para fazer uma
crítica nesse pouco e nesse efêmero
tempo mas uma clique crítica no sentido
de ser a que se desejo não é um desejo
de existência um desejo de humilhar o
outro um desejo narcisista social que a
todo tempo precisa ficar colocando algo
será será que esse macarrão que está
postado a pessoa comeu ele será que ela
não buscou e postou para poder criar uma
imagem uma representação algo que ela
tem que ficar a vida inteira sustentando
pra outro
uma das coisas que às vezes eu pergunto
para as pessoas é se você tivesse 24
horas de vida o que você faria que você
faria
a maioria das pessoas quando aperta o
sapato vai para o colo da mãe eu
encontraria meu pai eu ficaria essas
poucas horas com o meu filho com as
pessoas que eu mais amo na vida
interessante que em todas as respostas
100% ninguém nunca me respondeu que
ficaria 24 horas no facebook 24 horas o
instagram 24 horas e o que tem
acontecido
a coisa tá pizarro tubarão está matando
olha lá
na verdade o a selphy estão matando mais
do que tubarão o ser humano eu sei que é
uma coisa esquisita mas tá chegando à
onu uma falta de sentido como dizia o
grande pesquisador doutor victor
franklin de um vazio existencial é algo
que está nos aterrorizando e nós sabemos
que a representação é dessa vida
contemporânea
vida de pinóquio quem é o pinóquio
pinóquio é aquele que foi feito de
maneira aquele que foi construído sobre
uma medida
aquele que passa a vida inteiramente nu
em busca de uma única coisa que senti um
pouco esse instante de vida e nós
sabemos que a cada minuto que se passa
não é um minuto a mais de vida é um
minuto a mais de morte eu e você está
morrendo
todos esses minutos que passaram foram
minutos de morte de como coloca o grande
escritora eo emerson é que parece que
estamos numa velocidade como se
tivéssemos este ano estamos tendo que
manter algo constante né de uma maneira
alienada
parece que algo tem passado despercebido
em uma pesquisa que o doutor victor
frankl fez no livro em 2015 agora o
sentido de uma vida né pra avaliar essa
questão do vazio existencial ele
constatou algo inédito que foi ele pegou
jovens universitários e nesse contexto
ele foi avaliar essa coisa do sentido da
vida e verificou que 85 por cento dos
jovens diziam que não tem sentindo em
suas vidas
interessante muito interessante
a economia tem melhorado as coisas têm
melhorado tudo tem melhorado mas o
número de suicídio tem aumentado a falta
de sentido tem aumentado
essa desconexão completa
na verdade antes pára de chegar no atual
já está desconectado alegria se essa
pessoa cruzar com outra que consiga
fazer essa conexão que impeça a alegria
nesse contexto todo nós temos algumas
dinâmicas dinâmicas não adianta eu ficar
aqui só fazendo críticas não adianta que
eu ficar fazendo apontamentos mas algo
que é importante é importante entender o
ser humano é algo limitado ele tem um
potencial limitado ele conseguiu mapear
o genoma ele conseguiu ver que existe
algo além do planeta dele que existe
outras galáxias
o potencial do ser humano é m
quando ele está sempre expansão mas nós
sabemos que se colocar esse potencial em
prática algo volta mas para se colocar
em prática exige ação ação e toda a ação
que é colocada atrás com algum tipo de
resultado eu me lembro até muito bem de
thomas edison o inventor da lâmpada um
dia chegaram pra ele falou dó o senhor
gambuggi teve 10 mil e teve mil erros
para poder chegar até nessa lâmpada algo
assim
lembro que de maneira categórica ele
respondeu não eu não errei nenhuma vez
para chegar até a lâmpada
eu aprendi mil maneiras de como não se
fazer a lâmpada mas às vezes no primeiro
obstáculo nós já desistimos
os gigantes dos avatares não esses que
parecem de filme como beethoven
esses não esses dou a própria vida
nosso grande maestro também artur
moreira lima um dia
descendo do palco um jovem parou e falou
o maestro eu daria a minha vida pra
tocar como o senhor esses grandes sempre
tem algo muito bem preparada
ele respondeu para aquele jovem garoto e
disse eu dei a minha eu dei a minha
quantas horas ele não saiu por dia
enquanto que ele não percebe que se
desenvolver enquanto que ele não foi
para a ação quanto que ele não teve que
se manifestar
e esses resultados positivos quando
vamos pra cima pra frente
eles não nos dizem dentro da nossas
crenças coisas assim em inconscientes
você consegue você pode pode largo medo
vai pra cima faz a coisa acontecer
quando esse potencial ele não fica
explorado
o que fica não existe resultado vir uma
inércia
nesse contexto a voz que fica é você não
serve pra nada você precisa copiar
alguém você não tem alguém
cidade você é um saco de medo e aí o
convite aqui é 20 ao aprenda virar essa
chave
cada um aqui é um indivíduo se você
entrar dentro do banheiro e olhar uma
outra pessoa seja ver automaticamente
que ela é totalmente diferente de você
tem gente que fica procurando ser
diferente já nasceu diferente cristo
ciúme diferenciar olha pra dentro de
você olha pra todas essas potências e
traga isso à tona porque aí o seu
reforço ele vai ser positivo
aí você vai sair da posição de deveria
eu deveria estudar mais eu deveria falar
mais com os meus pais eu deveria a
contribuir com a sociedade eu deveria e
vai a posição de dever
aí você vai assumir a verdadeira missão
da sua vida é o seu dever e a vida é
curta mas ela não pode ser pequena e não
seja chuva passageira cij cachoeira não
procure pessoas que te complete procure
pessoas que ele transborde
sabe aquela pessoa que se encontre ela
te transborda você fala caramba
esses são momentos de instante é o que o
filósofo peter frederick smith dizia no
eterno retorno
se você tivesse que viver sua vida
infinitas vezes cada momento de maneira
exatamente como você viveu até esse
momento de hoje e você tivesse que viver
infinitas vezes você viveria essa vida
imagine você que agora olha que chegasse
nesse momento nessa palestra você
retornar e de maneira infinita você
viveria
se você respondeu 'não você precisa
tomar uma decisão muito forte porque a
sua vida não está valendo a pena
se você respondeu sim apesar de tudo a
sua vida está valendo a pena porque o
que eu e você quer
nós queremos olhar para trás
e vê que existe uma história algo que
faz sentido
observe ninguém tem inveja do sofrimento
do outro
ai que inveja de sofrer como aquela
pessoa como ela está triste que inveja
o que as pessoas têm do próprio
sofrimento quando passa por esse
sofrimento orgulho
o que nós temos do nosso próprio
sofrimento orgulho como foi difícil
pagar a faculdade mas eu consegui como
foi difícil abrir mão de muitas outras
coisas mas eu consegui
são esses tijolos que você vai
construindo o seu castelo
é nesse contexto é de olhar para o
sofrimento e consegui extrair algum
sentido algum sentido que tenha a ver
com a sua música é aquela sensação que
você sente que está se manifestando
sabemos que não é todo dia que tem pão
quente
tem hora que você está mais triste tem
hora que você está mais alegre
mas olha que notícia boa quando você tá
triste qual é a próxima coisa que pode
vim alegria quando você está alegre
seguro o tráfego que às vezes a próxima
coisa que pode vim a tristeza e nessa eu
oscilação
nós vamos buscando buscando construir
essa história essa imagem é pra fazer
uma reflexão e dizer o seguinte imagine
você
como será que foi o primeiro dia o
primeiro momento onde os dois primeiros
seres humanos se encontraram pela
primeira vez
como será que foi um olhando para o
outro
como será que foi esse encontro
porque até então parece que estava tudo
mas sobre uma conexão
houve uma conexão é tão a prova que
estamos aqui não estou sozinho aqui eu
não estou sozinho aqui nessa conexão
[Música]
quando você pára e ver o outro e não vê
você você se manifesta
existe o seu projeto o projeto do outro
em um projeto maior
a prova disso é que recentemente esses
gênios que viveram nove meses dentro da
barriga da mãe deles tiveram que ser
separados na hora do parto porque um
nasceu com problemas de saúde precisou
ser operado
a hora que eles nasceram tiveram que
separar os onze dias depois
essa foi a primeira cena a enfermeira
chega e coloca outro gêmeo um do lado do
outro
já existe a conexão
essa daqui é a maior prova de que
naquele contexto do nascimento
essa conexão já existe há anos
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]